(Transcrito por TurboScribe. Atualize para Ilimitado para remover esta mensagem.) Vamos passar aqui então para a análise de
editais e responsabilidades do arrematante.
Primeiro tipo de edital.
É o edital que isenta o arrematante de
débitos de condomínio em PTU, ainda que o
valor da dívida seja maior do que o
valor da arrematação.
Você só vai considerar isso se expressamente no
edital vier falando isso.
Algo do tipo desse exemplo que eu botei
aqui embaixo.
Responsabilidade de outras.
O arrematante receberá o bem livre de quaisquer
ônus tributários e débitos de condomínio.
Caso o valor da arrematação não seja o
suficiente para quitar tais dívidas, o saldo será
cobrado em face do antigo proprietário, não ocorrendo
substituição da dívida na pessoa do arrematante.
O arrematante somente responderá pelas despesas relativas ao
ITBI, transferência do bem arrematado e comissão do
leiloeiro.
Então você só vai considerar que você está
livre ali totalmente de PTU e condomínio, sem
precisar de fato analisar a existência dessa dívida,
se o edital expressamente colocar essa isenção para
o arrematante nesses termos que a gente colocou
aqui.
Segundo exemplo.
O edital que fala expressamente da subrogação dos
débitos de PTU e condomínio, mas não fala
na hipótese da diferença não paga com o
valor da arrematação, quando o IPTU e condomínio
supera o próprio valor da arrematação.
Exemplo.
Responsabilidade de outras.
Correrão por conta exclusiva do arrematante as despesas
gerais relativas à desmontagem, transporte, transferência patrimonial dos
bens arrematados.
Desmontagem e transporte não se aplica a leilão
de imóvel, é mais uma regra geral ali
que pode incluir bens móveis também que estão
na leilão, então para bem imóvel isso aqui
não se aplica.
Transferência patrimonial, aí sim você tem que registrar
o imóvel que você arrematou.
Continuando.
Excertos que se enquadrem no artigo 130 do
Código Tributário Nacional, parágrafo único.
No caso de arrematação em asta pública, a
subrogação ocorre sobre o respectivo preço.
E artigo 908, parágrafo primeiro do Código Presa
Civil, nos casos de adjudicação ou alineação, os
créditos que recaem sobre o bem, inclusive de
natureza a próprio terreno, subrogam sobre o respectivo
preço observado a ordem de preferência, salvo a
comissão do leiloeiro fixar em 5% da
arrematação.
Nesse caso aqui, o edital ele falou ali
expressamente do artigo 130, parágrafo único do CTN,
ou seja, se o valor não for suficiente
para quitar as dívidas tributárias, a dívida, a
diferença, vai ter que ser cobrada ali do
antigo proprietário, do devedor que é o executado
naquele processo.
Mas para condomínio, sinal de alerta, porque mesmo
colocando aqui o artigo 908, parágrafo primeiro, se
não falou de quem será a responsabilidade pela
diferença não paga do condomínio, aí sim essa
diferença seria cobrada do arrematante, conforme a jurisprudência
que a gente já estudou do STJ.
Terceiro exemplo, edital que determina a preferência de
pagamento para IPTU e condomínio e se o
valor da arrematação não for suficiente para quitá
-los, a diferença sobra para o arrematante.
Conforme determinado no edital, o produto da venda
será destinado ao pagamento de débitos de IPTU
e condomínio e caso o produto da venda
não seja o suficiente, a diferença será de
responsabilidade do arrematante.
Aí colocou aqui o montante de condomínio, mais
de R$ 500 mil, e o montante
de IPTU, mais de R$ 300 mil.
Então se esse imóvel não fosse arrematado por
um valor suficiente para quitar essas duas dívidas,
a diferença seria do arrematante, o próprio edital
já colocou ali essa hipótese.
Outro exemplo, edital que determina a preferência para
IPTU e condomínio e diz que se o
valor da arrematação não for suficiente para quitar
a dívida, o condomínio dá quitação ao arrematante.
Conforme determinado no edital, o produto da venda
será destinado ao pagamento de débitos de condomínio
e IPTU e conforme decisão da ata de
assembleia de 2018, essa ata de assembleia é
a ata do próprio condomínio, foi decidido que
o apartamento arrematado por ocasião de um leilão,
o valor arrecadado quitará a totalidade da dívida,
mesmo ela sendo superior ao valor do arremate.
E aí aqui tem a dívida de condomínio
de mais de R$ 1 milhão e
os débitos de IPTU de um pouco mais
de R$ 200 mil.
Então o que significa aqui nesse caso?
O débito de IPTU, ele seria pago com
o valor da arrematação, porque está dando preferência,
então ele receberia em primeiro lugar e o
débito de condomínio provavelmente não seria pago porque
é um montante surreal, provavelmente é um débito
maior do que o próprio imóvel vale.
Só que o condomínio, ele prefere dar quitação
do que continuar cobrando ao arrematante pela diferença
do condomínio.
Por que o condomínio prefere fazer isso?
Porque veja, a pessoa que está lá, que
é a proprietária daquele imóvel, está com R
$ 1 milhão de dívida, mais de R
$ 1 milhão de dívida.
Para o condomínio é jogo trocar esse proprietário.
Então mesmo que ele não receba o valor
integral, tira esse proprietário daqui, faz rodar essa
propriedade, bota alguém que de fato vai querer
pagar o condomínio que quer o imóvel.
E aí o condomínio começa a receber todo
mês o que ele tem direito.
Se o condomínio não desse essa isenção, provavelmente
ninguém arremataria esse imóvel aqui e esse imóvel
viraria um elefante branco.
O executado continuaria lá por anos porque ninguém
quer arrematar um negócio que vai sobrar uma
dívida para você.
Então o valor da arrematação aqui ficando abaixo
desse débito de condomínio mais IPTU, tranquilo para
o arrematante porque já tem a decisão lá
do condomínio, inclusive em ata de assembleia, colocando
essa isenção para o arrematante.
Então o arrematante pode realmente também arrematar sem
medo.
O edital que faz referência expressa o artigo
130, parágrafo único do CTN, e estipula de
forma genérica que outras dívidas do imóvel serão
de responsabilidade do arrematante.
Esse aqui é o exemplo mais comum do
que a gente encontra na prática.
O edital falando expressamente ali dos débitos tributários
com o artigo 130, parágrafo único do Código
Tributário Nacional, mas deixem aberto ali outras dívidas
que possam existir.
Eventuais ondas sobre o imóvel correrão por conta
do arrematante, exceto eventuais débitos IPTU e demais
taxas e impostos que serão subrogados no valor
da arrematação nos termos do artigo 130, capa
de parágrafo único do CTN.
Então esse edital aqui fez a isenção dos
débitos tributários, mas ele deixou em aberto o
condomínio.
Só que nesse caso aqui a gente tem
que analisar o concurso de credores.
E exatamente o que está aqui.
Para os casos em que o edital apresenta
a possibilidade de responsabilização de débitos condominais anteriores
à arrematação para o arrematante, é necessário analisar
o concurso de credores.
Qual é a finalidade de analisar esse concurso
de credores?
É saber se o valor da arrematação deverá
quitar as dívidas penhoradas do matrículo do imóvel.
E o concurso de credores vai estabelecer a
ordem de preferência das dívidas penhoradas existentes, determinando
a ordem como as dívidas serão pagas.
O concurso de credores também serve para evitar
o enriquecimento ilícito do devedor.
Então vamos entender aqui para que serve de
fato o concurso de credores.
O concurso de credores vai estabelecer a ordem
que os credores daquele devedor devem receber os
seus valores.
Porque é muito comum que o devedor deva
para vários credores.
E aí qual será a ordem com que
esses credores serão pagos?
Exatamente o concurso de credores que vai falar
isso para a gente.
E por que evitar o enriquecimento ilícito?
Vamos supor que o devedor tem um imóvel
que está indo a leilão por dívidas de
indenização de um acidente que ele causou.
Mas nesse imóvel também existem penhoras de dívidas
de condomínio e existe uma dívida de IPTU.
Como quem está levando a leilão é esse
processo da dívida de indenização, não seria justo,
por exemplo, que o imóvel fosse arrematado por
R$ 300 mil, essa dívida de indenização
chegue a um montante de R$ 100
mil, e aí esses R$ 300 vão
pagar os R$ 100, vão sobrar R
$ 200.
Não seria justo o juiz liberar esses R
$ 200 mil na mão do devedor, porque
o devedor tem outras dívidas.
E esse devedor, se isso acontecesse, ele poderia
sumir com esse dinheiro e não pagar as
outras dívidas.
Agora, nesse nosso exemplo aqui, eu falei que
o imóvel está indo a leilão por uma
indenização de um acidente que o devedor causou,
e ele tem dívidas de condomínio e IPTU.
Então vamos supor que, de fato, o juiz
liberasse ali os R$ 200 mil.
Se o juiz fizesse isso, quem arrematou aquele
imóvel ficaria responsável por dívidas de condomínio e
IPTU anteriores à arrematação, enquanto o devedor vai
receber um valor na mão dele e deixar
para trás uma dívida que ele causou, afinal
de contas ele não pagou o condomínio e
IPTU.
Isso nem de perto é justo, isso seria
um enriquecimento ilícito do devedor, porque ele causou
dívidas, vai deixar de pagar aquelas dívidas, repassar
as dívidas para outra pessoa, que está entrando
naquela relação ali completamente de boa-fé, o
arrematante é um terceiro de boa-fé, ele
entra para dar liquidez para que dívidas sejam
pagas, enquanto isso, o devedor vai se aproveitar
ali daquele valor que ele vai ficar na
mão dele e não vai pagar as dívidas.
Isso nem de perto é justo, isso seria
um enriquecimento dele, que vai passar para outra
uma dívida que ele causou e vai ficar
com um montante na mão dele.
Então o concurso de credores serve para isso,
para estabelecer essa ordem dentro das dívidas que
aquele devedor possui e também para evitar esse
enriquecimento ilícito.
A ordem do concurso de credores qual é?
Em primeiro lugar, recebe créditos alimentícios, que são
os créditos trabalhistas e pensão alimentícia.
Esses créditos têm natureza absoluta, eles sempre recebem
em primeiro lugar, porque eles são créditos que
o credor precisa receber até mesmo para se
alimentar.
Então a pessoa trabalha porque ela quer ganhar
um salário e com esse salário ela precisa
viver, inclusive ela precisa comer com aquele salário.
Se ela deixa de receber aquele salário, como
ela vai arrumar dinheiro para se alimentar?
Pensão alimentícia é a mesma coisa.
Entre as várias despesas que englobam ali uma
pensão alimentícia, está a própria alimentação de quem
tem o direito de receber aquela pensão alimentícia.
Então por isso que eles são sempre em
primeiro lugar.
E aqui uma observação muito importante.
O crédito trabalhista, ele entra em primeiro lugar,
mesmo que ele não esteja apenhorado na matrícula
do imóvel.
Então vamos supor que você está olhando um
leilão e aí naquele leilão você abriu a
matrícula daquele imóvel.
Tem lá uma apenhora de condomínio, tem lá
uma apenhora de indenização e não tem nenhuma
apenhora trabalhista.
Você não pode deixar de pesquisar se existem
processos trabalhistas daquele devedor.
Porque se você fizer isso, pode ser que
entre a data que você está analisando aquele
leilão e aquela matrícula e até a data
efetiva da liberação do dinheiro no pós leilão,
surja um credor trabalhista ali cobrando aquele valor.
E aí esse credor trabalhista vai bagunçar toda
a ordem de concursos de credores porque você
deixou de considerá-lo.
E o STJ entende que o credor trabalhista
passa na frente, inclusive se ele não tivesse
a apenhora averbada ainda na matrícula.
Então ele pode entrar por último na matrícula
que ele vai receber em primeiro lugar.
Por isso que nessa aula aqui, nos anexos
ali embaixo da aula na descrição, tem um
campo com o link de todos os TRTs,
que são os Tribunais Regionais do Trabalho, para
que você pesquise se realmente aquele devedor, que
é o proprietário do imóvel que está indo
a leilão, que você está analisando, tem dívida
trabalhista ou não, tem processo trabalhista.
Se aparecer processo trabalhista, ligue um alerta, porque
esse processo, se ele entrar por último, ele
vai bagunçar o seu concurso de credores.
O credor trabalhista, mesmo chegando por último, ele
vai receber em primeiro lugar.
Então muita atenção com isso, nunca deixe de
analisar se existe o processo trabalhista contra aquele
devedor, que é o proprietário do imóvel, para
que você faça uma análise correta e depois
não seja prejudicado por esse credor trabalhista que
está chegando ao final.
Segundo lugar são os créditos tributários.
Então se o devedor está devendo alguma coisa
de imposto de renda e a União está
cobrando, é um crédito tributário.
O próprio crédito do IPTU é um crédito
municipal, que também entra aqui nessa segunda regra.
Terceiro lugar, créditos com garantia real, que são
exemplos da hipoteca e alienação fiduciária.
Por que garantia real?
Porque existe um bem específico garantindo o pagamento
daquela dívida.
Então na hipoteca existe um imóvel garantindo o
pagamento daquela dívida, na alienação fiduciária existe um
imóvel garantindo o pagamento daquela dívida, então créditos
com garantia real.
E no quarto lugar, os créditos penhorados na
ordem cronológica das penhoras.
E aí é realmente na ordem cronológica, que
aparece em primeiro, segundo, terceiro, quarto, quinto, e
assim por diante na macrícola do imóvel.
Existe uma exceção a essa ordem de preferência,
que é a exceção que está na súmula
478 do STJ.
Na execução de crédito relativo a cotas condominais,
ou seja, no processo movido pelo próprio condomínio
para cobrar esse valor desenclarado de condomínio, os
créditos condominais têm preferência sobre o crédito hipotecário.
Então vamos voltar aqui.
Dentro dessa ordem aqui do 1 ao 4,
onde se encaixaria o crédito condomínio?
Não é um crédito alimentício, não é um
crédito trabalhista e nenhuma pensão alimentícia, não é
um crédito tributário, o condomínio não é um
crédito tributário, não é um crédito com garantia
real, porque o condomínio não fica garantido com
uma hipoteca ou uma alienação fiduciária, então o
condomínio entraria no quarto ponto, créditos penhorados na
ordem cronológica das penhoras.
Então você precisaria ver lá na matrícula do
imóvel em que ordem está a penhora do
condomínio e assim você saber se realmente ele
será pago.
Agora, a exceção diz que se for um
processo movido pelo próprio condomínio e tiver uma
hipoteca, o condomínio sai do ponto 4 e
fica acima do ponto 3, acima da hipoteca.
Então a ordem seria créditos alimentícios, créditos tributários,
condomínio e aí depois hipoteca.
Então essa é uma exceção aplicada quando o
processo for movido pelo próprio condomínio.
Continuando aqui, agora vamos avaliar a relevância das
penhoras existentes na matrícula e o que dispõe
o edital sobre as dívidas do imóvel, o
que de fato você precisa se atentar a
cada tipo de edital que você encontrar.
Então primeira situação, o edital dispõe expressamente que
o imóvel será repassado livre de dívidas e
que se o valor da arrematação não for
suficiente para quitá-los, a diferença será cobrada
do devedor.
Esse caso é de segurança total para o
arrematante que vai arrematar o imóvel livre de
qualquer débito e se por acaso o valor
não for suficiente para pagar esses débitos, a
diferença será cobrada do próprio devedor e não
do arrematante.
Situação 2, o edital dispõe expressamente sobre o
artigo 130, parágrafo único do CTN, que é
o que fala do IPTU, e o artigo
908, parágrafo primeiro do CPC, mas nada fala
sobre a diferença caso o valor da dívida
seja maior do que o valor da arrematação.
Nesse caso você vai precisar analisar, sim, a
ordem do concurso de credores para saber se
o valor de condomínio e IPTU serão pagos
com o valor da arrematação.
Caso o valor dessas dívidas seja maior do
que o valor da arrematação, considere que você
será responsável pela dívida de condomínio.
Por que a dívida de condomínio?
Em primeiro lugar, o IPTU será pago na
frente do condomínio, porque o IPTU é um
crédito tributário e o condomínio vem depois na
ordem do concurso de credores.
Relembrando a ordem, crédito trabalhista, pensão alimentícia, crédito
tributário, crédito com garantia real e depois os
créditos na ordem das penhoras e aí sim
entraria o condomínio.
Se for uma execução do próprio condomínio, o
condomínio passa na frente do crédito hipotecário na
ordem.
Mas vamos supor que você está analisando aqui
e o edital colocou dessa forma que os
débitos serão subrogados, mas não falou se existir
a diferença.
Nesse caso, como tem ali o artigo 130,
parágrafo único do CTN, e o IPTU vai
ser pago na frente do condomínio, não importa
se o valor não vai ser suficiente para
pagar o IPTU, porque mesmo que isso não
seja suficiente, a diferença será cobrada do devedor,
porque é assim que a jurisprudência entende.
No condomínio é diferente, se o valor não
for suficiente para pagar o condomínio, a diferença
será cobrada, sim, do arrematante.
Então você precisa sempre analisar se o valor
daquela arrematação vai ser suficiente para pagar os
créditos preferenciais, se existirem, depois IPTU e condomínio,
e aí sim você vai ficar livre de
dívidas.
Terceira hipótese.
O edital dispõe expressamente que as dívidas tributárias
e condominais serão pagas preferencialmente com o produto
da arrematação, mas que se o valor da
arrematação não for suficiente para quitar tais dívidas,
a diferença será do arrematante.
Nesse caso, o edital está puxando ali a
preferência na ordem do concurso de credores para
condomínio e IPTU, então serão pagos até na
frente de outros credores.
Você vai precisar realizar o levantamento das dívidas
de condomínio e IPTU, somar essas duas dívidas
e verificar se o valor da arrematação vai
ser suficiente ali para pagar essas dívidas.
Se o valor da arrematação não for suficiente,
você deve de cara ficar fora desse leilão?
Não, coloque lá na sua viabilidade financeira.
Pode ser que, sei lá, que sobre um
saldo ali de 10 mil reais que você
vai ter que pagar, mas ali, considerando o
desconto que aquele imóvel está sendo levado a
leilão, ainda assim vai ser vantajoso.
Pode ser que na sua viabilidade financeira, mesmo
você assumindo ali algum gasto de condomínio e
IPTU, ainda assim seja interessante.
Quarto caso.
O edital dispõe expressamente somente o artigo 130,
parágrafo único do CTN e coloca de forma
genérica que outros débitos do imóvel serão de
responsabilidade do arrematante.
Isso aqui é o mais comum da gente
encontrar.
Você vai precisar realizar a avaliação das penhoras
registradas na matrícula, estabelecendo a preferência do pagamento
de acordo com o concurso de credores e
verificar se o saldo da arrematação vai ser
suficiente para quitar os débitos preferenciais, incluindo o
IPTU, até chegar na penhora de dívida de
condomínio.
Se o valor da arrematação for suficiente, arremate.
Se o valor não for suficiente, faça o
levantamento do débito de condomínio e avalie a
sua participação.
Por que, nesse caso aqui, que o edital
só coloca o artigo 130, parágrafo único do
CTN e não coloca o condomínio?
Por que, nesse caso, para saber se o
condomínio será pago, você precisa considerar o IPTU?
Porque, olha, lá na ordem de concurso de
credores, o crédito tributário vem antes do crédito
condominal.
Então, você antes vai pegar aquele valor da
arrematação, vai pagar credor trabalhista e pensão alimentícia
se existir, depois vai pagar crédito tributário se
existir, depois vai pagar crédito com garantia real
se existir, depois você vai entrar ali no
condomínio.
Então, o valor da arrematação vem abatendo todos
esses créditos.
Para você saber se o condomínio vai sobrar
para o arrematante ou não, depois que todos
esses créditos forem abatidos, você precisa considerar o
montante do IPTU, naquele valor que você vai
observar se vai sobrar para o arrematante ou
não.
Mesma coisa que antes, se o valor da
arrematação for suficiente, arremate.
Se não for suficiente, verifique ali se você
vai participar ou não daquele leilão.
Lembre aqui sempre de pesquisar por processos trabalhistas,
porque mesmo que não exista penhora verbada, se
ela entrar por último ali entre a sua
análise e a data da liberação do dinheiro
do leilão, vai impactar no seu concurso de
credores.
Então, você precisa considerar essa penhora.
O arrematante nunca é responsável por dívidas que
não sejam do imóvel, à exceção lá no
leilão judicial de direitos, quando existe alienação fiduciária.
Mas dívidas do devedor, apesar do arrematante não
ser responsável por essas dívidas, elas podem impactar
na responsabilização das dívidas do imóvel pelo arrematante,
porque se tiver uma penhora trabalhista, ela vai
receber aquele produto da arrematação, e aí ela
pode impactar na diferença que vai sobrar do
valor da arrematação para pagar IPTU e condomínio.
Então, essa é a importância de você avaliar,
e aí realmente você ficar bem prevenido sobre
aquele caso.
Caso não exista penhora do crédito condominial para
esse último caso, o exemplo 4, que é
esse aqui, o edital dispõe expressamente o artigo
130 do CTN, que é a subrogação ali
no preço do IPTU, e coloca de forma
genérica outros débitos.
Então, se não existir a penhora do crédito
condominial, você vai ali observar na matrícula que
não tem aquela penhora, mas você vai ligar
para a administradora do condomínio e vai descobrir
que existem débitos.
Nesse caso, você deve considerar que esses débitos
serão pagos por você na sua viabilidade financeira,
mas nada impede que, após o leilão, o
arrematante faça o requerimento para o juiz de
que esse valor do crédito condominial seja pago
com o produto da arrematação.
Essa hipótese é possível porque o artigo 908,
parágrafo 1º do CPC, fala que os débitos
de próprio terreno devem ser pagos com o
produto da arrematação.
Agora, se não existir a penhora do condomínio,
considere que esse débito vai ser seu, para
não atrapalhar a sua viabilidade financeira.
Depois do leilão, se o juiz aceitar pagar
com o produto da arrematação, beleza, melhor para
você, porque você vai lucrar mais ainda do
que estava esperando, porque você não vai ter
essa dívida.
Mas, ali de cara, considere que essa dívida
vai ser sua se o crédito condominial não
estiver penhorado.
E, de uma forma geral, nada impede que,
depois da arrematação, em qualquer tipo de edital,
o arrematante realize o requerimento para o juiz
e peça a preferência do pagamento de IPTU
e condomínio com o produto da arrematação, conforme
o artigo 908, parágrafo 1º do CPC.
Porém, a gente deve sempre considerar o concurso
de credores se o edital não for cristalino
sobre o pagamento dos débitos de imóvel para
ter segurança na arrematação.
Então, apesar de você poder fazer esse requerimento,
nada te garante que o juiz, de fato,
vai aceitar aplicar o valor da arrematação para
pagar condomínio e IPTU.
Então, por uma garantia, sempre que for necessário,
avalie o concurso de credores, para você não
dar um tiro no escuro, para você saber,
de fato, o que você pode esperar daquela
arrematação, sem contar depois com uma decisão favorável
do juiz.
A gente nunca deve contar com uma decisão
favorável.
Essa decisão pode acontecer, mas se ela não
acontecer, a gente deve estar preparado para as
consequências de uma decisão que não vai ser
favorável, que é pagar condomínio e o IPTU,
ali, de acordo com a sua viabilidade financeira.
Pode ser que você considere que o valor
de desconto que está sendo oferecido no leilão,
de fato, é tão grande que, mesmo assim,
vale a pena você arrematar, assumindo esses débitos.
Muita atenção em leilão da Justiça do Trabalho.
A regra da Justiça trabalhista é somente a
subrogação no valor da arrematação dos débitos tributários,
ou seja, o arrematante vai ficar livre dos
débitos tributários.
Na maioria dos casos, a responsabilidade pelo pagamento
dos débitos condominiais é do arrematante.
Se o edital em leilão da Justiça trabalhista
for omisso, os débitos condominiais serão de responsabilidade
do arrematante, sem nem analisar concurso de credores.
Então, tome cuidado com o leilão da Justiça
trabalhista, porque é diferente do que a gente
falou aqui anteriormente na aula.
Só vai ser a regra, realmente, a subrogação
do débito tributário.
Você vai analisar no edital se realmente está
subrogando no preço do débito tributário, porque aí
sim o arrematante vai ficar livre do débito
tributário.
E se não falar nada do condomínio, o
condomínio será do arrematante, sem nem analisar o
concurso de credores.
Atenção, porque essa é a exceção do que
a gente estudou anteriormente na aula, por ser
um leilão da Justiça trabalhista.
Vamos aqui, então, para a parte prática dessa
avaliação do concurso de credores.